ich habe sich rat gehört noch schlafen
gehört von rechtskräftig
ich sehe die kuh ich sehe die kuh ich
finde ihren tod im moment würde ich
jetzt von allen seiten angegriffen
von allen seiten damit hier ich helfe
dir ich stehe mit einem endermann in
einem kleinen raum
da steht er neben mir
herzlich willkommen zurück zur capt if
minecraft 2 teil 16
die kühe sind also wir haben gerade auf
ihr habt gerade zwischen den aufnahmen
einfach kurz unsere sachen sortiert also
ich hab kommen ein paar sachen
wiedergegeben paar sachen habe ich
behalten
ich bin noch gestorben dummerweise immer
mehr portale oben muss man sagen ich
habe noch ein paar bisschen was gegessen
mit meinem herzen hier voll sondern
alles möglich ist ein paar sachen halt
nix wichtiges und die sind die kühe sind
gerade unter unsere treppe irgendwie
nach unten gelaufen also die werdet ihr
jetzt gleich hier beurteile bestaunen da
sind zu lassen die für das chaos ein
bisschen gewachsen die kakaobohnen auch
wieder sehr schön die welt
die wölfe sind immer noch richtig
ergriff die filme sind richtig oder
hatte ich jetzt aber schon plan und zu
habe ich hier ein bisschen fleisch oder
bringt vielleicht überhaupt was also ich
glaub schon also wenn man den viel
fleisch gibt ich habe nur zwei gerade
mich natürlich aber ich habe drei
gegessen auch wegen meinem herzen gerade
war wie sega heute das letzte fleisch
gegessen
ich hatte auch noch welches aber es ist
nicht guckt mal okay dann herzen aber
jetzt immer noch groß
wir müssen warten planen planen und noch
eine andere frau ich habe genau bundes
sollte es noch nicht ja wir haben da
dieses tropenholz siehst du das daher
warte mal und da können wir auch noch
wartet so etwas draufsetzen
ich habe auch noch den eichen setzling
und die erde also viele stücke er da
habe ich bestimmt das müssen wir gleich
auch noch machen und zwar was ich als
erstmal gucken wollte man mache ich mal
demo kirche ich selbst schon mal die
erde und dem baum ja mach das was ich
gucken wollte was war das denn was ich
machen wollte
ich wollte die zäune mitnehmen dann
wollte ich noch eine neue zaun tür
machen und dann hab ich nämlich ganz
kurz mal ein plan ich glaube sogar dass
kann ich alleine kurz machen mit den
wölfen
das ist ja so ein tier folge jetzt hier
ein bisschen wir sollten vielleicht erst
mal noch ein bisschen zuckerrohr und
flache zuckerrohr
du hast noch ja denn ich habe nämlich
gerade gar keine er
oder hast recht ich habe noch also ich
hab noch reichlich erde ich habe noch
hier immer noch zwei einer kiste dann
passiert in 13 34 im überschuss hier
oben gerade ok erwarte ich nehme eben
noch die hak und pflanzen neues an und
dem dann auch knochen
du hast alle knochen oder ja ich habe
hier schon mal die mauer der bauma und
sieht schön aus man schöner brauch auf
jeden fall hinfällig mal okay ich hab ja
klar ich habe gar keine gar kein knochen
doch da sind knochen ok super ich bin
glaube ich ja da hast du glaub ich noch
da ich kann ganz klar ich hab gerade
drei von gelernten mehreren sodann
pflanze ich da mal ganz kritiker wer
hierhin jetzt habe ich mich erst mal
drei stück um die kür daraus zu lotsen
das ist so krass sondern zeige ich euch
gleich mal noch diese tolle arbeit
kommen die kühe an ihr euch will ich
nicht wie die da oben so und zwar kommt
jetzt meinen super toller plan ich
glaube jetzt die treppe hoch wir können
diese treppe eigentlich auch mal zu
bauen hier ne da kommen immer notiere
durch manchmal machen wir haben immer
unsere dass wir uns einfach ihr
aufgefallen ist so wartet er kommt als
es tor
das heißt mein plan war ich mache da es
unglaubliche und zwar baue ich die hunde
1 uhr soll die hunde sind eingebaut
so und jetzt lohnt sich nämlich die
schafe hier raus moment hier kaputt bau
neben dem blog auf gold im blog auf
emerald ihn können wir jetzt schon
machen also beim winzer geht weg
schaffen
walter nein schaaf schaaf schaaf nein
richtig wohl nachdem ein gott nein also
bist du klavier und scharfsinnig schafe
brauchen wir nicht oder brauchen die
schafe billig wofür wir wenn schon doch
nur für wolle und wolle haben wir auch
aus den ganzen seidenen teilen also grob
überlege gerade an später denken wir so
scheiß werden wir jetzt wieder schauen
wenn schon ja nur für betten aber der
unten weg geht allen die dafür nämlich
für tränke nicht das kann mitmachen
wir können ja mal überlegen ob hole was
aus wollen aber ich glaube dann brauchen
die wohl eine doppelte schutzmauer teil
aber da kommt man auch erreichen das
gehege oder mach das mal eben so man
kann aus wolle halten bett bauen das
hätten wir wissen können
ja da haben genug wolle für ein bett das
habe ich schon ach so ok ja keiner dass
sie da so viele mein gott diese drohne
sind ja mal so aggro ach was da wolle
färben aber jetzt wenn ich als
farbmittel nutzen ganz genau einfach
aufstellen vorjahr 29 bonbon alter jetzt
holt also ein fetter baum
endlich haben wir holz ohne ende oh mein
gott ok gut
hier ist auch noch holz das manchmal
noch immer aber ich glaub ich genug holz
endlich alter diese diese hunde
ich überlege schon gerade wofür wir das
brauchen wir für wir hier ist erde
darunter aber erde gefunden wo hier war
er darunter drei erde
ich würde sagen wir verbrachten die fahr
mal nach hier oben weil hier so viel
wasser unten drin wird es immer enger
das heißt das werde ich jetzt mal machen
ich nehme meine schaufeln grab hier drum
rum was
so deutete das am besten immer nur zwei
für die bäume der erde für die farm
nachher oder wir schmücken unsere bäume
und machen daraus solche bäume ist die
einfach nur ein mal senkrecht nach oben
gehen ich räume wie den hier wo ich
gerade dran bin
es ist dies aber so verschwenderisch mit
dem holz um holz warum das denn roger
ist kein holz dran
hast du noch mehr das war mal ein baum
ich habe dass sie mit der schere
abgehört jüngst hast du noch sonst doch
eher dürftig erde nie habe ich aber hier
überall verteilt auf der karte
okay gut ich nehme einfach mal zwei erde
hast du für deine baum fahren und half
ihr weggenommen
warum fahren wir es im baum farm jawohl
ich bin der farmer region ist das denn
dann so hast du noch knochen für mich
ich habe knochenmehl aber keine knochen
ja knochen mir geht auch wo bist du denn
konnten weil meine höhle dadurch nicht
wie ich das möchte muss kommt ja ich
komme sofort ich wollte hier unten eher
allgemein mir alles eben können wir
diese momente wohl abbauen können wir
die sind ja schon fällig so was meinst
du ein stück er dass wir hier hier
gelassen
herr wurden ich habe kein monument blog
mal abgebaut
ich glaube ich muss sagen ich habe ein
bisschen angst nicht dass das doch nicht
richtig war und wo hast du die erde
welche art von der du ihm gesprochen
hast die habe ich schon hingesetzt da
allen vom das denn wann denn direkt am
wasser weil da eine farm hinkommt hertha
konnte voll cool gefahren hin doch immer
schon so war zu tropenholz nämlich noch
mit anpackt dann nämlich ganze
kakaobohnen noch dran man dass ich
dieses holzmarkt rede da noch
kakaobohnen da da so dann packt ihre
sachen mal wiederwählen den kirstein
stimmt das zuckerrohr könnte ich
mitnehmen nach oben
können wir das noch an pflanzen da ist
auch noch eine kakaobohne drin wenn man
kein programm das alte bauwerk auf bund
für farbe und genau eventuell auch kekse
ich überlege staatschef mit kermani
backen oder kies oder irgendwie sowas
kann ich mir gut vorstellen die darpa
balla balla balla balla balla ich komme
jetzt mal die wölfe schon bisher unten
hin
also wenn du hier bist war der des
knochen mähne da liegt welches ich hab's
wie ein gesamtvertrag hier zeigt dass du
so dankeschön die hacker habe ich dabei
okay so war das video unten kühe haben
kommen schon die grüne gerade die höhle
sie gerne duelle aber gott sie haben ab
wie in captain feinkost 1 junge männer
doch hilfe der was machen wir jetzt bei
woher bekommt wir werden kein wasser
mehr doch für stück kommen schnell
herunter guckt jetzt mal an die scheiße
es kann sich sein design entworfen jetzt
verstehe ich was alle meinen soja diesen
höhle bei captain mir richtig bock auf
höhen und da ist nicht mal eine treppe
das körper von ein gott genau neben den
kulissen krüper online wenn die weg
locken oder so im fall könnten wir töten
damit dürfen aber nicht die kuh die
gewinnen genau daneben steht treffen
alter [ __ ] was machen wir jetzt
ich versuche mal die kühe von hier oben
mit dem ok es klappt aber sie kommen
nicht hoch bei der einen blog fehlt hast
du denn abgebaut als welchem block nein
etwas was heavy was habe ich mal da
unten fehlt ein blog für die treppe
findet so vielleicht kommen sie ja zu
hoch
junge junge junge diese scheiß kühe
immer eher eine kuh in eine falsche
richtung ja ja ja bitte
jetzt kommt auch sie stecken fest mit
dem kopf
nein doch leider nicht noch langen noch
gar nicht noch leider lange nicht ich
bin gerade so angespannt wie er wegen
der blöden kühn wenn die weg sind dass
wir und hoch jetzt da ist der club genau
neben den kühen aber ich mag sie hoch
kommt ich habe hier etwas erweitern muss
man ganz gut was nach gucken so moment
ja bla bla wieder ins wiki muss ich
gehen
wegen einer kleinen sache die ich mal
nachschauen wollte bla bla bla bla bla
bitte habt ja jetzt noch einmal sprechen
springt doch endlich blöden kühe
na also so blöd sind jetzt in der
caritas nachtbetrieb hat sie
weggeschoben vergleicht wird der krippe
hat weggeschoben von der stufe eben
gerade elf und kommt jetzt kommt schon
hoch kommt schon hoch stecken auch schon
wir fest so ich bin gerade mal ganz kurz
am plane neben blabla hier brauche ich
noch die sachen
wo sind die kühe lesen noch hier unten
sind sie noch in gefahr
der compiler lebt noch größer denn
schafft es ein fall brauche noch
schießen soll schießen der macht okay
ist super kann auch ein jahr warten eine
spinne ich gehe lieber wieder
ja bitte und jetzt hoffe ich mal komme
dass da jemand kommt
du weißt was ich eigentlich schon die
ganze zeit in diesem krieg gedacht haben
wir brauchen ein fachmann kuchen dass
das dass das für mich arbeitet in diesem
scheiss kuchen hier
deswegen muss ja grad nach unten zu den
kühen kurz sommerschau nicht genossen
alles frei geworden
das ist auch ein bisschen sie kommt ein
alter noch eine tief wir sind bei der
nächsten truhe da ganz oben
jetzt springen doch du dumme kuh sie
schafft den sprung nicht weniger wegen
der tür
wahrscheinlich ist ganz unten auch
wieder irgendwas freigesetzt worden das
ist bestimmt unten wieder in mit tropfen
oder so aber wir sehen es einfach nicht
weil wir gerade hier oben am beschäftigt
sein tun sind noch das heißt wirklich
beschäftigt sein tun sind
das ist richtiges deutsch kommt es dass
da kommt das wasser raus sowohl sind die
kühe sie kommen einfach nicht diese noch
weiter runter oder was was die tür die
bbq ist eigentlich noch weiter runter
aber zweifel reichen erstmal die babys
nicht so wichtig ist um auch noch ein
oder was aber wir können ja wieder pan
weiße jacke mal eine er aber doch nicht
einer alleine eine kuh ist ja wir haben
nur eine kuh gerade denn die andere ist
ganz unten und dann kannst du mal eben
schon runter kommen ganz schnell
ja klar warte ich bin direkt unterwegs
also die kurs schon mal wir oben eine
kuh die müssen wir mal eben da kommt der
hexe hilfe kommt ich bin hier
ich habe direkt ich hab die excel
wechsel ist tot alter hat man einmal die
tür abgebaut und jetzt die kuh schnell
einbauen
mit welchen sachen da deswegen wollte
ich dich herum warte mal
okay ich mache schon werden zäune auch
noch die natur ja damals erzeugen so
habe ich die denn die waren doch hier
mal drin 8000 sind
ich habe auch welche nein nikolov act
die cool effect lanciert dem sticker
stehen bleibt man emma ich bin ganz
ruhig bleibt ruhig
das war super gesetz komme er besser was
macht ihr denn was für eine chance ich
guck mal was in der hand halte diese
beiden hier ich wollte sagen
nach der kurs nach unten baum am besten
neuer kanal können die da noch an der
seite langlauf nicht abschieben kann
sich jetzt auf jeden fall gar nicht mehr
junge junge dass auch die eimer hast du
noch gold oder so wollt
so emerald brauchen wir auch noch was
ich war mal ganz kurz was ich da
freigesetzt hat da sehe ich noch nicht
einmal blog auf gold und block auf
emerald brauchen wir
was sind das hier so viele blöcke warte
hier ist pink ich schaue einfach mal
nachher noch mal nach was ihr daraus
machen können und zwar mache ich mir das
alles in der nächsten folge alte von wo
kommen die alle obwohl das sie mit den
crews grad wichtig ja eigentlich schon
dann machen wir es noch ein bisschen
weiter wir hier schon all days are so
schlecht ausgeleuchtet da jetzt weiß ich
wo die ganzen monster kommen und wo ist
die kugeln sagt nicht diese mühle
sie ist nicht in die ist in die höhle
reingelaufen jetzt können eigentlich
schon mal sagen gut baku alter scheiße
der höhle voller krüger und voller
zombies und voller skelette wenn dir
überhaupt da wenn wir unter gesprungen
ist ist der falsch 100pro tot
wir müssen noch mal reingucken jetzt in
einer folge am besten kommen aufnahmen
nach unten
da habe ich gerade einen blog zum helm
neben dorthin gemacht darunter darunter
alles was hier sind erst mal ganz viele
zombies löchern krippe hier musste
gucken
hier sind ja schau mal das war falsch es
war so guck mal hier guck mal hallo
kongo fia
alter ich glaube dass die rennen
gelaufen es stimmt ich habe auch noch
pfeile sechs stück ich sehe die nicht
ich sehe dass die aber ich habe sie
gerade gehört noch saufen gehört von
rechts kräfte immer einfach mal ich sehe
die kugel auf die crew
ich sehe die kunden ihrem tod im moment
würde ich jetzt von allen seiten
angegriffen
von allen seiten kommen hier ich helfe
dir ok labs noch lebst noch bestandes
meldung ich stehe mit einem endermann in
einem kleinen raum
da steht er neben mir kommen junge ist
durch ihr idol wechsel ergab stellt
komplett einstellen vor dem block abwehr
sind wir sind halt diesen safe hier ist
ein moment nicht an
jetzt geht dürfte durch vergibt ich habe
einer teil herzen da seid ihr ja glaub
scheiße komm ich hab nichts zu essen was
essen sie gebaut brauche ich auch noch
blocken hast was zu essen
ich kann nicht lange zeit in kontakt ich
habe durch meinen herzen
ich brauche nahrung alter ich habe eine
halbherzige auch nahrung wartet das
fleisch das mache was ich generiere
sofort wieder ich wir werden erstmal die
folge und morgen geht es dann weiter
lesen
wir sind schon fast bei 20 minuten wir
machen schnell ende pass auf hör auf du
kannst du kein schlagen
dass die räuber oder hast du gehört ich
habe tag und tod ist diese vollkommen
bekomme wehrt euch gefallen er zeigt
sich schon damals und bis morgen
dollar